the Justice Department is defending
Attorney General William bars summary of
the special counsels report after
criticism over how he reported on its
findings Barr concluded there was not
enough evidence to prove obstruction of
justice by President Trump or anyone
else but we're learning that Robert
Muller's team disagreed over that issue
Paula Reid is at the White House Paula
good morning good morning
Anthony next week when William Barr
heads to Capitol Hill for his first
hearing as Attorney General he is
expected to face a firing squad of
questions about the Special Counsel
investigation as Democratic lawmakers
renew their focus on the Russia probe a
CBS News has confirmed there was a split
with Ian of the Special Counsel team on
this question of whether or not the
president obstructed justice with some
investigators believing the president
had committed a crime and that's part of
why Muller did not come to a conclusion
on that issue and made a point to
acknowledge that there was evidence on
both sides of that question now House
Judiciary Committee Chairman Jerry
Nadler has requested all communication
between the special counsel and the
Justice Department after several news
outlets citing anonymous sources claims
some investigators feel Barr did not
accurately convey their findings to
Congress and House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
also seized on those reports to bolster
her demand for the full mulher report
but in a rare statement the Attorney
General shot back insisting every page
of the Mullah report was marked with a
warning that it could contain
confidential grand jury information var
also said he continues to work on a
redacted version of the Mullah report
that he expects to release in mid-april
Anthony well the president's former
attorney Michael Cohen says he has
information damaging new information
damaging to the president what evidence
does he claim to have well with just
about 30 days to go before he begins a
three-year prison term Cohen sent a
letter to lawmakers saying that he has
accessed a hard drive with approximately
14 million files and he would like to
help them sift through these and
continue his cooperation if only they
would be willing to either delay or help
reduce his prison sentence but federal
prosecutors are unlikely to go for this
as they have criticized Cohen's
cooperation and their investigations as
being incomplete
Anthony Ola thank you well that's one
way to dangle it the other by the way I
have all this others are amazing here
this hard drive that I've just found
million files that you might be
interested more to come more to come
thank you